and so the health secretary said on sky
news the fuel situation is stabilizing
in most parts of the country
is that correct well breaking news on
sky we've just completed our survey of
over a thousand sites across the uk
and the situation is very much better
than it was yesterday
and 68 of sites have both grades uh 16
have one percent or one type or the
other and so only 16
compared to 26 or 27 yesterday have no
fuel and now dry
it's much better in the north and
scotland and london and the southeast
really remains the critical area going
forward into next week
so the situation improving just reveal
those figures again 16 because for days
you have talked haven't you of a quarter
or more
of your four courts which the ones that
you operate which let's face it is what
65 percent of the uh country had no fuel
at all but
16 17 is that what you're saying
just 16
uh so that's a really a big sort of ten
point improvement
over where we've been for the last uh
three or four days and um the
retailers report uh less surge buying so
we've got to thank the public either for
having full tanks already or a little
bit of restraint which we think was very
much needed is very welcome by us all
and of course in addition to that we've
had the government coming forward with
the military drivers uh retailers report
they're already out today uh training
with existing drivers and i'll be ready
to start we hope on monday taking their
own tankers around
and in addition to that uh the
government have extended the visa
position by three months until the end
of march next year
specifically for about 300 htv drivers
that they're hoping to bring in from the
continent so whilst we're not out of the
woods we're certainly looking better but
just around the corner i'm afraid uh the
next shock is pricing uh because this
week uh the wholesale price for both
unleaded and diesel has gone up by three
pencil
pencilita
nothing at all to do with the fuel
crisis in the uk
all to do with global factors of brent
crude creeping up to nearly eighty
dollars a barrel and sterling
unfortunately weakening a little bit
against the u.s dollar
so because we've had no stock
the new stocks coming in from the old
companies will be at the increased
wholesale prices
so consumers can expect price creep at
the prompt next week by one two or even
three pencil liter and this is not
profiteering not price gouging this is
purely global factors coming into play
affecting the wholesale price
so your retailers can put up prices by
as much as they want can they
no they usually put up the prices
according to what margin they've decided
is right for their business they're all
independent so those margin requirements
can vary a little bit
but they generally
put up the prices as the wholesale price
increases and of course because they've
had no stock
there's no old stock to sell at the old
prices these will generally be at the
new prices coming in is everyone going
to be putting up their prices then in
the next few days
already and if they haven't already and
so many have as we know
yes there's been one or two uh points of
uh profiteering
we certainly don't condone that at all
amongst our members most of our members
have got neighborhood
transient sites where they've got
regular customers and if regular
customers have been exposed to any form
of profiteering uh they've quite likely
not to return and that's what those
particular filling stations deserve they
should not be price gouging by up to ten
peer liter as one or two instances
this is a
industry-wide movement because of
wholesale prices increasing because of
the global factors i've mentioned
just one question for you there is you
say the situation is starting to improve
on your forecourts however what do you
tell people in the southeast of england
and specifically london who a can't find
fuel or b are having to queue for for
hours we've asked the government to
prioritize the
um independence because there are so
many of them we have 65 percent as you
mentioned of all four courts and these
independent forks tend to be very much
public facing in your neighborhood on
your transit route so easily seen by
consumers as they drive to work take the
kids to school go to hospital whatever
other appointments they've got so until
particularly in london the southeast
until these filling stations
start to get to work again and the
public see them i think it's going to be
difficult to completely
regain all the confidence that has lost
being lost in recent days